hundreds of thousands of people
celebrating Independence Day in the
nation's capital will face dangerous
heat temperatures in Washington will
feel like the upper 90s
this comes after excessive heat warnings
there yesterday when temperatures felt
like 109 degrees Kris Van Cleave is on
the National Mall in Washington Kris
good morning good morning the nation's
capital remains under a heat emergency
as it's going to feel with the heat
index close to a hundred degrees out
here on the National Mall as hundreds of
thousands of people come out for the
annual 4th of July fireworks celebration
now DC fire it's already seen 10 to 15
cases of heat exhaustion a day and of
course there's a lot of concern about
what this day will bring as so many
people gather here on the mall the city
has already added additional cooling
centers here and that's in addition to
about a half dozen or so a first-aid
tents that will be on the mall dozens of
first responders will be here to help
anyone affected by the sweltering
temperatures and the humidity excessive
heat warnings yesterday did not stop
workers from preparing for the
celebrations including getting 6500
fireworks shells into position those
fireworks are scheduled to kick off just
after 9 o'clock tonight there's a number
of 4th of July parades in town DC Fire
will be deploying fire engines to those
to essentially act as giant misters to
try to keep the crowd cool tonight when
those fireworks begin the forecast is in
the 80s but the heat index will make it
feel a lot hotter than that
Anthony Kris Van Cleave thanks Kris